only two years now after the January 6
Riot the law enforcement officers who
defended the U.S Capitol will today
receive the highest honor issued by the
U.S Congress that would be the
Congressional gold medal Scott McFarland
reports now on the tribute to police who
risked their lives to fight off that
violent mob
she was among the first wave of officers
to arrive on the west front of the U.S
Capitol as the mob approached and then
attacked Capitol Police Officer Shea
Cooney says not a day goes by she
doesn't recall January 6th not only the
size but the way they were you know you
could see the anger you could see the
hostility so a lot of us were just kind
of shocked that something like this was
actually happening with weapons with
weapons Capitol Police Lieutenant Ted
Hopkins first tried to stop the mob in
the Capitol visitors center before
racing to the U.S House chamber after
rioters sought to breach the door of the
speaker's Lobby it's important to relate
how bad it really was from the verbal
abuse from the actual physical assaults
to the chemicals impact weapons in the
months after January 6 Congress passed
formal legislation to bestow medals to
the police agency's present making it a
special day not just for the officers
who saved the capital but their families
too what was it like to be a mom that
day with your son here it was
I mean obviously the worst day of his
life but without a doubt the worst day
of our life Kathleen Doby calls as her
son a five-year Capital officer still
works for the agency but rarely speaks
about January 6th then likely carries
Trauma from it today she says she'll be
beaming with pride you know he's very um
he's very humble he doesn't like to be
called a hero
but um
but he's my hero
the legislation ordering these medals
formally mentions the officers who died
after January 6. Brian sicknick who died
of multiple strokes and the officers who
died by Suicide they'll be a focus area
of this ceremony today which happens
inside the capital rotunda a site of
rioter attacks Gail that was such a
horrible day Scott I'm glad those
officers are being honored you can see
how it affects his mom thank you very
much Scott